hello everyone watching a YouTube video
can be fun entertaining educational but
reading a good article can also be those
things so that's why in the link there
is a link in the description below where
you can read a full article about demis
hassabis he's the founder of deep mind
and well directly responsible for alpha
0 existing so I decided since alpha 0
has been filling our days with the joy
it would be very nice to see a game by
demis hassabis the founder of deep mind
and in the article you will find a lot
of interesting stuff
Demi's isn't it wasn't only a chess
prodigy who was a prodigy in pretty much
everything he did well when he was 8
when he was 6 years old
he won the under 8 London championship
and I mean he bought his first computer
the ZX Spectrum at the age of 8 with the
money he won in a chess match so a lot
of interesting stuff there while he was
when he was 13 years old he became a
chess master and he was the second
highest rate second highest rated under
14 year old in the world first one was
of course you did pole guard so I you
know I encourage you to read it and
let's see let's see this game he's
playing against Peter Hein and Nielsen
the game was played in 1992 and Peter
Nielsen is a danish grandmaster he
wasn't a grandmaster at the time this
game was played i think two years after
this game he became an international
master so he was definitely on the rise
and his the Kapadia page also says that
he became a grandmaster in 1994 but you
know it sounds a bit weird that he
became an international master and the
grandmaster in the same year so you know
the wikipedia you know doesn't always
tell you the truth so if anyone knows
when peter nielsen became a grandmaster
to share in the comments but it also it
might be in 1994 but that being said
let's see the game and demis hassabis
was raided around 2300 when this game
was played
see for then it says the white pieces g6
we have the English opening in the g6 is
something called the great snake
variation
efore Bishop to g7 Knight to c3 d6 we
have G 3 g5 now better - g2 and c6
Knight G 2 e 2 preparing to Castle
Bishop to e6 d3 now f5 and Demi's
castles Knight to f6 and me 3 Nielson
castles Bishop to a3 now pinning the
spawn x-range rook on f8 ruku f7 e
captures on f5 Bishop captures on f5 and
d4 now and the white manage to solve all
of his problems in the opening he
managed to push d4 still have to still
have to develop the Queen and get the
rooks into the game night - a6 and we
have D 5 and here Nielson it has the
option of either pushing c5 or maybe
capturing and after Knight captures
something like e 4 but then you're stuck
with this d6 pawn a backwards weak one
for the rest of the game not something
you look forward to
so after d5 he decided to close the
position with c5 we have h3 now h5 f3
now definitely preparing to push g4 h4
and now g4 Bishop to d7 and now Queen
can come to see to the queen is
developed and the ribs are ready to
enter the game and now this queen is
attacking the g6 pawn and how do you
defend this it's not at all clear the
best way to do it would be to play
something like King to h7 and this this
seemed like this seems like a
counterintuitive move you you know place
your king in front of the Queen but like
is actually the black king is fine here
white would go for something like Bishop
to see want to transfer the bishop to
the other side and after a move like b5
go fish up to g5 and it's it's a it's a
better position for for white but
it's a very sharp position so black can
definitely hope for something but
instead after Queen c2 Nelson played the
g5 he defended the pawn by pushing it
but he allows Queen to g6 and now the
Queen is really in there and threatening
to grab the g5 pawn Knight to h7
defending the pawn and here Nelson
offers this d6 pawn and it's a very
interesting variation what happens if
Queen captures on d6 if Queen captures
on d6 then rook to f6 kind of almost
trapping the Queen the Queen has to
capture the pawn on e5 you capture and
now this bishop you line up your queen
with this bishop on on g7 and okay the
room doesn't have any discoveries at the
moment and not any good discoveries but
after Queen to a5 attacking the bishop
on a3 Bishop to b2 and now rook rook to
e8 attacking the Queen you only have one
square for your Queen all the other
squares are taken you have to go to h2
and this is the position you have to see
before you decide whether you want to
capture the pawn on d6 and you have to
evaluate what what do you do now is
black better here is white better here
and it's it's pretty complicated I mean
how do you get your queen out of h2 in
the end then Adam is decided not to
capture the d6 pawn but he decided he
wants to play Knight to e4 and this is a
very elegant solution to this problem
now he's again threatening to capture
and on d6 with the night he's also
threatening to capture on g5 and if if
black decided now to give up the d6 pawn
he's falling apart
then his c5 points which is e 5 point is
weak and this is terrible so you can't
give up this pawn you have to defend it
only way to defend it is rook to f6 and
now you're simply capture it Knight
captures and f6 was played with Czech
Queen captures Queen captures and Bishop
captures now that misses up the exchange
and even though Nielson at the time this
game was played was rated
around something below 2450 you know a
very high rating but them is is a very
capable player he's able to win this
being up the exchange Knight to c3 was
played Bishop to be eight nine I 24
attacking the bishop and the pawn on d6
Bishop to e7 defending rook a to d1 now
Bishop to g6 Bishop to c1 we have King
to g7 a3 now rook the c8 Bishop to e3
Knights to be eight the night has to
come back into the game somehow rook to
see one Knight to d7 rook to F to the
Bishop captures on e 4f captures on e4
and the night h 2f 8 and now rook C to F
1 threatening to bring the roof to f7
win the bishop so Bishop to f6
we had rope to f5 and the rope is the
rope is a well placed on f5 black
doesn't have a light square bishop to
kick it away from there and you don't
have time for Nagi 697 because your Jeep
on is hanging g5 pawn so night to h7
defending and now rook to be 1 preparing
to push the pawns on the Queen side b6
bishop to f1 and the idea is that this
bishop will will at some point come to
d3 then c2 and then at some point to a4
and will will be very strong on this
diagonal Knight d2 f8 before now came to
f7 be captures on c5 we have he captures
D captures on c5 and rook to f2 now the
rook is coming to the Queen side Knight
to d7 now Bishop to d3 Bishop is now
coming to a for King to e7 Bishop to see
to night back to f8 and now a for
preparing a 5 to break open this
structure Knight to d7 now a5 was played
ripped the c7 and the bishop to a4 and
in this position
Peter Nielsen resigned the game it
doesn't really matter what you play
you're going to
who's this night and then then white is
simply breaking true you could try
something like night h2 f8 to defend
this but after rook f5 now your night
isn't really able to defend the g5 pawn
anymore and you're falling apart rook to
be b7 maybe to defend the pawn but then
Bishop to c6 this is this is all
terrible after something like rook here
you simply either capture or go row k1
probably row K 1 and after B captures
then you capture and black is black is
terrible here you're losing this point
you're losing this pawn and a player
strong like someone as strong as Peter
Nielsen doesn't want to play this end
game anymore
so yeah after this Bishop to a4 move
Peter Nielsen resigned the game and it
was a very nice victory for for the
founder of deepmind demis hassabis so
yeah I was worried I was really I mean
I'm not surprised that demis hassabis is
a chess player I was just very surprised
to see that he was such a strong chess
player at such a very young age and he
also created his own video game when he
was 17 years old called theme-park
and then he founded his own a video game
company and then later in 2010 he
founded a deep mind which he later I
don't know I think it was some three
years ago or something sold it to Google
for somewhere I read 400 million pounds
somewhere I read 260 million pounds but
it doesn't really matter you know if you
have millions and pounds in the same
sentence that's that's a lot of money
but you know 400 million pounds and
sounds like a lot like a lot of money so
yeah our congratulations to demis
hassabis for such great accomplishments
in pretty much any field he touched and
I do hope you enjoyed it and I do hope
you read the article there's quite a lot
of interesting information about them is
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon